It's a good question.
Yeah.
Only Ben can answer this.
Correct. I know Jeremy said he'll be a few minutes late. He was wrapping something up.
Yeah.
Okay, no worries.
In the meantime, while we wait for Ben, which I hope it joins.
I'm checking.
We have time.
So before we go ahead with the presentation, I will let...
Andy, I'm sorry, Addy and Kobe.
Ask questions as per NOC, and then we can look at the presentation.
So, over to you, gentlemen.
Thank you, Kevin. So nothing critical from my end. So any feedback for NOC team?
From the server side, anything you see concerning?
Yeah.
Not not for me, that would be that would be a question for Ben.
Kobe, anything will be alright.
No.
Thank you so much, Addy. I am all good.
All right.
That was pretty fast.
Kip.
So you guys want to stick around? I mean, I don't know if Ben will join and if he has any questions, then either I can pull you in or you can just...
Be on this call.
Yeah, sure.
Sure. Thank you so much, guys, for your time. Have a good day.
Okay, Kobe wants to drop, so he's like, I'm dropping. Kevin's going to pull me in. But don't really, Kobe, I'll pull you in. So if you have other things to do, you can go ahead and you can drop.
Yeah.
It's been.
Thank you, Kevin.
Okay, in the meantime, what I'll do is...
I'm going to share my screen and we will look at the presentation. Okay.
Akshay.
Let me know when you can see my screen.
That's good.
I hope you can see it.
Alright, why is Megan so serious?
Sorry, I'm waiting. This is this over here is you guys. This over here is my e-mail.
Yeah, that's why when I look at you, you were like so serious that maybe I hope.
That's probably in my face the entire day. I'll try. I will try to work on this.
Ha ha ha.
It's Tuesday, so we have time.
Okay, cool. Yeah, we have Jeremy. Hey, Jeremy, welcome.
Hey, hey, good morning. Sorry about that.
Have we just started? No worries, we just started. So welcome to our monthly service check-in for NTI networks. As per the agenda item, it stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights, performance analysis, all the schedule.
Build it, Team GPS, way forward, and then meeting minutes. As per the highlights, the biggest highlight from last week is that, from last month, is that Rachel has been promoted to Senior Helpdesk Support Specialist. So that's a promotion on our side. Okay.
Ohh.
So just wanted to share this news with everyone.
But still, congratulations to her.
Yep, yep. And Akshay is also getting ready, but for Akshay, it's a little bit more difficult because he's going for the advanced level. So he's already at a senior level right now. So he's preparing for the advance. But overall, he is like certified as per SC300 and AZ104. And then the team continues to meet their service expectations with a focus on SLA address.
and continuous improvement. So these are the few, you know, highlights. Anything that you want to add before we move on to the next slide?
I don't think so.
Nope.
Okay, cool. As for their performance analysis, overall, Annie was at 52%, Rachel 61, Akshay 66. For the month of June, Rachel and Akshay, they were able to exceed their benchmark score. Annie, however, did well. We all know where she's struggling.
But as per the team, if I look at it, on an average, they are around about 60%.
So anything that you want to add, Ashley, Jeremy, Megan?
I should not pick on Megan because Megan is obviously not the one who is working closely with the team. It's Jeremy and Ashley.
Addy.
Show.
Just because my camera is visible.
Yeah.
Haha.
Well, I usually turn it off while we're paying attention to the to the...
Mm.
Well, Ben is here, so Ben is here. So, hey Ben, we miss you, but thanks for joining.
Good evening. Hi then.
You're muted.
You're speaking on mute. He has to say everything again.
Sorry, Ben, still not able to hear anything. You're facing technical issues, Ben.
There we go. Call IT. Yeah.
Oh, sorry, you're talking to me. No, someone showed up to my house to do some work and it came right at 1030, so.
There you go.
That's what Mary Beth said when I called her.
Yeah.
But we're happy that you're here, so thank you so much for joining, Ben. We just started. Let me do one thing. Let me just stop sharing my screen and as per our...
usual stuff, we're going to go with to the NOC team first. So I have Addy. So Ben, if you have anything for the NOC team, you can go ahead and let Addy know about it.
Addy, you with us?
No, I don't have any.
Yep, yep, on here.
Anything?
So can we let Addy go then? Because he was patiently waiting for you.
Ah.
Pre.
Addy, for the NOC team, actually I did think of one thing. We're switching our VMware hosts to Proxmox.
But.
Mhm.
Do you guys have any experience with Proxmox, like monitoring it? Okay, all right. I'll have to, we don't have additional, we don't have enough hardware to do them all at once, so we're doing them one at a time and moving things around. So that project will be going on starting.
Yeah, we do, we do.
Mm.
I don't know, in a couple of weeks, but I'll, I'll, we'll let the NOC know when things are going to be going down and things, and then once it's once we convert them, I guess we'll need to find out how you guys want to have access to the new Proxmox versus the...
VMware.
OK.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ben. Over to you, Kevin.
Okay, thank you, Addy. So if you're good, feel free to drop. If you want to stick around again, I'll say the same thing. You can. Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you, Chopra.
All right, so Ben, we just started. Let me just go back to our previous slide. We were just discussing the highlights, so I just want to go back to the previous one. Well, the big news is that Rachel, she has been promoted to senior.
Helpdesk support specialists. That's on our side. I was just telling the team Akshay is also getting ready for his level up. That will be as for the advanced level. So they both are preparing in a way that.
Now they can handle more complex tickets on your side. So feel free to test them. That's what I can tell you. As they, you know, go ahead with the promotion on our side, we want you guys to assess them, test them, and see where they stand as per their knowledge.
Yeah, I did. I had got through exercise with Rachel this morning, so she's doing good.
Yeah, I know something happened. I she told me that something happened.
Well, I just said, they did a ticket and they closed it and I was like, well, you can't, you didn't, we didn't really ask all the questions. So anyway, it turned out good. She did a good job.
Yeah.
Okay, cool, but she told me that something happened as I was like, no way.
I mean, it ended up that the ticket was solved properly, but I said, we really can't know that this is the right answer unless we at least ask a couple more questions. And so, but that's, it was, it turned out they did the right, they answered it. They were right in the first part.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
That's good. That's good. Questions when you ask, it will give you clarity. And I think that's where we all struggle at times because we assume things and we all know what happens when we assume things.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have a saying here for that, but I don't.
Yeah.
I was hoping it'd be the same. That's why I was like, assumes what? What does that mean?
Something like.
Yeah. Yes, I know.
Yeah.
You guys know the Singh?
Okay.
I know it. I just don't want to say it.
The only reason I know how to spell it.
We all know it, it's a, yeah, I think around the globe it's the same thing, so I think we we all know it, so we're on the same page, because so we were just assessing their...
Okay, good.
Billable KPI as per last month, June month, we're looking at June's data. Akshay, Rachel, as always, they're doing great as per they're billable. And even though she's struggling, but that's something that I think, Ben, we already discussed, and I just wanted to let you know that next week we will have Sneha.
Snares on boarding, but that will happen next week. We'll keep you posted. So, this team, this team knows right that very soon and he will not be part of this group. Do we know this?
OK.
We, we were, we knew, but we we didn't know it was official, I think, but it we were in the we were in the know.
Okay, yeah, so looking at the current scenario, she's struggling with her health, you know, what's happening at her pace with her father. So things are not good at her. And so, yeah, very soon. That's why we wanted to make sure that we have
Sneha, who's the replacement engineer for Annie, she will be joining us next week. So you'll get more details from us.
OK, ticket closure rate again, Rachel Akshay doing phenomenal above the goal, and he was at sixty-seven percent, but yeah, looking at the scorecard, looking at their KPIs, I mean...
Akshay, Rachel, I have no question. They have been doing phenomenal work.
Jeremy, Ashley, anything from your end?
Um, I don't think so.
Yeah.
No, not really.
Okay, cool.
Been doing pretty good.
All right, perfect. Jeremy, you've been watching FIFA. Who's watching FIFA, by the way? Is anyone watching FIFA?
Ha.
I've been watching.
I've been keeping track of it.
We are. Last night, though.
I know, last night, yeah.
Yeah.
Maybe we're not talking about last night. We're not talking about last night.
Last night was terrible. We got, I mean, yeah, that third goal was awful.
Well, you know what they say that.
I could have, I could have stopped that.
You know what they say? They say that there's a curse because of Trump. And anytime he gets himself involved, like we lose.
But.
Mhm.
We deserve it!
Yeah, so I'm not a huge fan of soccer.
Yeah.
Rump.
There's actually a funnier thing kind of going on with that whole thing.
We want to turn this into Trump bashing. I'm happy to oblige. I can go on and on.
There's a...
Yeah.
No, Namit.
Yeah, no, no, I just was reading about that today that there are some curse they were talking about.
Yeah, you hear a lot of things. Obviously, you know what happened last night, you're not talking about it. But overall, I think we are very happy from my perspective that you are getting new teams now challenging the big giants of soccer. So to me, that's a good sign. When you see like teams like Norway, you know, coming in.
Ohh.
We have that small country like Cape Verde challenging, yeah, challenging Argentina. So yeah, so that's a good sign. So we don't want a domination from one country where that's not how it should be. So let's see, let's see. I'm excited for France, Argentina. They have been playing very well.
Hey, Verde, yeah, they did phenomenal, so.
100%.
Argentina is here today. They're here in Atlanta today. There was a bunch of people marching downtown.
Friend.
Oh, that's cool. You're gonna watch Messi? That's nice.
Yeah, my son went to one of the games last week, England. Who did he go to? Not the, not the...
England.
That's England versus Mexico, if that's the case.
Versa, yeah, Mexico.
No, what was the one, but what who did they play before that? It was...
England versus wasn't.
Maybe Seattle?
Ahh.
It was something in Atlanta. I thought it was in and maybe it was if they're in Seattle then it wasn't that he's here in Atlanta. Anyway, he was he was like...
I don't know, had the afternoon off and he just looked, the game started and then the tickets dropped in price, like it went by half. So he was able to get a good price on the ticket.
Mhm.
Oh.
I'm hearing the tickets are so expensive, right? It's not cheap and it's like crazy expensive. So good luck with that if you're getting it at a half price.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, after that, he still paid a lot, but it was only a few $100 versus thousands, you know.
Yeah, crazy prices are ticket prices are crazy, man. It's an expensive sport. Anyways, getting back to our usual things, so next holiday is on.
Right.
Okay.
September 7th, Labor Day. So we have time. I think we can discuss if you need the team during Labor Day. But rest, apart from that, I haven't heard anything else.
No.
Me.
I think we are good as for the scheduling piece on the holidays, so yep.
Moving on, as for the shift schedules remains the same for all three, no change, so...
Yeah.
I see Sameer joining in. Thank you, Sameer, for joining in. Build it. I think registrations is done, right, Ben? And then overall, you're coming. Okay, awesome.
Yeah, we're three of us coming.
Yeah.
All right, AI by design will be added to our build it agenda. That will be on August 5th. So you will get a lot of insights on day 3rd.
Team GPS, we all know about it, we're going to skip it. Focus overall remains the same. We just want to make sure that the team continues to perform well and provide value to NTI. And I think that's where our focus is. And hopefully once we get the new person in,
Ohh.
things will be more streamlined. And if there are any roadblocks, then together we'll overcome all those. So that's pretty much it from my side. I'm going to stop sharing my screen now. I'm going to open up the floor. So I'll go over to Ben, you first, since you joined late. So
Over to you.
Yeah, I don't have uh too much. Um, nice.
Right now, I...
Oh, hey, Sameer.
Hey Ben, how are you guys? I'm good, I'm good. I joined it purposefully, just wanted to say hi. And looking again, forward to meet all three of you if you guys are coming. That's what I heard from Andy and the team. Yeah, yeah, I'm good, I'm good. And Shashank probably will also be flying. So we, you're going to say...
How you doing? Good. It's been a while.
Okay.
Okay, you're going to be there again? That'll be good. All right.
Yeah.
Ohh.
Okay, because he didn't make it last year, I think, right? Or I didn't see him anyway.
Both of us.
No.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, so he should be there this time along with me.
Okay.
Yeah, no, I'm good. The question I had was for the onboarding of the new person. Does that, I mean, remind me how that, do you guys handle that there, like?
Yeah, Evan, can you help me with that? Yeah.
Yes.
Does Jeremy have to be highly involved in that or?
No, so yeah, we'll send you the updates next week. By next week, we'll give you all the details to you, Ben. And I think tentatively, I'm looking at July 15th. That's the date we are targeting. And beforehand, we'll give you all the details.
Okay.
Okay, I'll get with...
Hear me about the new person to replace Annie coming up. The only other thing I had was I will be out of town that week before Build It. So that's the 26th through the 1st. I'll be out of town and mostly unavailable that week.
Yeah.
So if anything you need from me that week, I'm going to be at a scout tamboree thing. I'll be like living in a tent. So I should have cell service, but I'm not going to be working that week.
Ketan.
Okay, understood. Yeah. So I think the only help that we need from your end will be for the credentials. So I think that's something, do you think? Okay.
Jeremy and the guy, they can handle that at the Helpdesk.
I apologize, what day do we say was the start date?
Then I think we should be good.
The 15th.
We're targeting July 15th, that's Wednesday.
Okay, I'm going to have to talk with some of the other guys to possibly cover for me because I'm actually going to be out next week. I'm going to be visiting family over in Delaware.
Yeah, no, no one I'm sure can handle that.
Oh yeah, yeah, 100%.
I will be, I will be in town and I will be working.
Yeah, and I'll be, and I'll be around next week, too.
Yeah, no one's pretty good at filling in for me when I'm not available, so he should definitely be able to help out.
OK.
Okay, sounds good. And uh...
Oh, if you don't mind me asking, like, so are they going to be like located in the same office with Akshay and Rachel or? Okay. Cool, cool, cool. Awesome.
Yes, yes, yes, same office.
Even if, let's say, you don't have time, she will be sitting with Rachel and Akshay. So all three will be.
Okay.
Yeah, that's the blessing in disguise, sort of a thing, Jeremy and Ben, that she's going to be in the same office. We want all three at the same place, sitting next to Gaurav and Gagan, me, and also in that office, right? So that we'll have the entire team sitting at one place.
That'll be nice. Yeah, that'll be helpful.
Cool.
Great.
Okay, great. Thank you, Ben. Jeremy, over to you. Any questions, concerns, feedback?
The only feedback I have, it's very minor stuff. Obviously, I'm always available to try and assist with any of the technicians' questions. You know, me, Patrick, Nolan, A, the local team and everything. I do want to make sure that when they're asking us for questions, obviously, you know, use all your resources before you ask them for help.
just general basic stuff. Also, there's been a little bit of trouble with when they're asking for help, they're incredibly vague. I do want to make sure it's kind of hammered into their head that like, hey, you know, what client's this for? Like, who's the user? What machine? Just like have everything all spread out so that we're not playing a guessing game. Because sometimes I just.
Mhm.
Boo!
You know, like, let me just go and say, like, actually it's fantastic. Like, I can trust him with most cases and he can handle stuff without a problem with minimal interaction for me. But sometimes he'll just send me screenshots of things and I have to literally stop what I'm doing to go and try and research, like, okay, what are we talking about? Which tickets this for? Who's this for? Because I don't have all the stuff memorized, like.
what computer or who has what. I just want to make sure they're a little more aware to have all this stuff front and center before they're asking for help. That way we can kind of, you know, get them helped out, you know, as quick as possible, that kind of thing. The other thing was...
Yep, yep.
Do we have any method to provide better training for them as far as Macs go? So we don't have many clients that have Macs, but I do notice that they're struggling as a whole with supporting those. And whereas, you know, we don't mind, you know, taking those tickets from time to time. Obviously, we want to make sure that everyone knows how to do everything.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yeah, so I I'll take it as a to do here. So, Kavan, if we can just work with the L&D team, give them the soft training, retraining with the Mac piece, because I know that there are a lot of pieces in UK and US where there are a lot of clients who works on just Macs, like probably on the designing part, Acrobat piece. I also suffered a lot during my engineering days. They're not easy peasing, so...
Mhm.
Kip.
Yeah.
Please work with the team, see if they can give them some training around this. We do have a Mac, Jeremy, in office where we do have the trainings that can be done and aligned. So we do have the module. So come on, just work with them, create that module, get it blessed by Jeremy and the team if he finds it good. Give them the training for one or two weeks and then we can take it from there.
Mhm.
Sure.
Right.
Ansh.
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah, and honestly, it's nothing crazy too. Like, it's honestly just, it's bare bones basic stuff. I just want to make sure they're comfortable navigating around in there, making profiles, things like that. You know, we don't usually do anything crazy for Macs, but again, I just want to make sure they're comfortable working in it and not just be like, what do I do? You know?
Absolutely.
Can we?
Yeah.
And we have...
No, I completely understand. Yep.
Yeah.
We have a Mac for business purposes, specifically to use for training and for testing and things like that. So if they need, it lives here at my house, so with me, so they can always just ask me if they can't get on it because it should be on screen connect and all that.
So, actually.
Yes, yes.
Oh.
Yeah, so we do have, we have a couple, I guess. I'll just check it again. So, Khan, you are there. I'm in Noida today, so if we can check it quickly, what is the part of the training and if they can do the hands on as well.
Okay.
Sure, absolutely.
Thank you, Jeremy. Over to Ashley.
Cool.
Uh, I, I have, I don't have much.
I've been happy, they're good.
Okay, awesome. Thanks, Ashley. Megan.
Yeah, everything seemed to be covered.
Thank you, Megan. Andy?
Just wanted to ask Ben, Ashley, any requirement for Build It? I think you guys are registered, RSVP, all things are done. If you have any questions, need any support, just feel free to ping me or e-mail me and we'll be happy to assist and wish you a very happy, very good experience during Build It and I'll be meeting you after Build It.
Okay.
Sameer and Sushant will be there with you during build it. Thank you.
Oh.
Sounds good.
All right, awesome. Thank you, Andy. Uh, Sameer, over to you.
I'm good, I'm good. I'm excited to meet this team again. We had a good time last time as well. And we built up Ben together and it's going to be different again since Sushant will be there. He was more connected with the Ben in the team more than me. But I said it will be good to meet them in again person.
Awesome.
Thank you, Sameer. Well, that's all from our side today. I will see you after Build It. We're 100% sure you're going to have a great time during Build It. So looking forward to that, and we'll see you next time. Until then, have a good one. Take care. Bye bye.
Yep.
Thanks, Kris. Alright, bye.
Thank you, bye-bye.
Great, thanks guys. Bye.
Awesome. Thanks guys. Bye bye.